[موسيقى]
أولاد لي مثل هذا الجزء الكبير من هونغ
كونغ والتاريخ هنا أنسى
أنك تعرف كم هو مثير للاهتمام
ومدى إثارة المراسلين في هونغ
كونغ
[موسيقى]
كان هوك الأول عبارة عن لوحة نسخ إلى حد كبير
في غالبية الحاوية
سيكون الشحن هو ما تعرفه ، لذا يعمل
مثل محور كتاب عجلة الدراجات ويتحدث بشكل
أساسي ولكن منفذ محور في منتصف
الكثير من التوقف الإقليمي
[موسيقى]
يمكننا أن نأخذ القارب مباشرة إلى
منطقة الميناء ونحصل على عرض رائع عن
قرب  أن العمليات تقوم بتحميل
حاويات التفريغ
وتقترب حقًا من سفن الحاويات
نفسها أيضًا ، أعني أن معظم الناس
سيعيشون في هونغ كونغ لكننا نحصل على الكثير من
الأشخاص الذين يأتون
لأسباب تجارية
يسافرون إليها  أكثر ما أحبه في الصين
هو أن هناك عددًا قليلاً من الأشخاص
الذين مروا ثلاث أو أربع مرات
وأنت تعلم أنهم عادوا وتريد
أن تسمع المزيد من الأشخاص يرغبون في رؤية المزيد والقيام
بذلك مرة أخرى
[الموسيقى]
أنت